[Music]
20:16 felt like an unprecedented year
for indie games from fire watched
stardew valley to even no man's sky
games coming from independent studios
and tiny development teams shook up the
gaming industry and for better or for
worse capture the attention of the
entire world but that was last year
that's old news now the real question is
what do we have to look forward to this
year well to help you guide you on your
way here our picks for the hidden gems
that you need to look out for in 2017
if you've ever wanted a 2d Dark Souls
game look no further than deaths gambit
the game's pixel art and animation is
drop-dead gorgeous but they play second
fiddle only to the game's ridiculously
difficult bosses taking hints from
Castlevania Shadow of the Colossus and
the Soul series deaths gambit will offer
players plenty of weapons and abilities
to take down the behemoths that traverse
is forsaken lands
from the developers behind 2013's co-op
heist game Monaco comes tooth and tail a
beautifully animated arcade style RTS
game players take control of an army of
woodland creatures waging war across an
unlimited plane of procedurally
generated Maps despite its simple
looking controls you can and are
encouraged to play the game with the
controller the combat is exciting and
offers a level of depth on par with any
realtime strategy out there
created entirely by one man gorgoa
combines incredibly detailed
illustrations with heavy comic-book
elements to create a puzzle game like no
other by stacking and unstacking each
picture you'll be able to connect the
drawings and create some unbelievable
scenes within each frame
whether you play it for the gameplay or
just to admire it's lovely art gorgoa
looks to be that cathartic experience
for us to all rest our eyes on
if you've ever wondered what it's like
to be a bat perception might be the game
for you former Bioshock and Dead Space
developers have teamed up to create the
first-person adventure game that will
test your fears as well as your senses
as Cassy a blind woman who's looking for
answers in mysterious mansion you'll
have only your echolocation powers to
guide you through the darkness combine
that with some excellent sound design
and you've got an unsightly horror game
worthy of your time
developer Thunder Lotus impressed
everyone with their first game yotan and
they're looking to once again dazzle
players with their new game thundered in
what they're calling a horrifying fight
for survival insanity you'll wander
across an HP Lovecraft inspired world
battling grotesque creatures and
hopefully keeping your mind intact by
the end and with its eye-popping
hand-drawn art style Thunder looks
absolutely stunning
what was once a ps4 exclusive is now
coming to all major platforms and thank
goodness because rhyme looks like the
adventure game we've all been missing in
our lives
set on a mysterious island you'll
traverse the ruins of an ancient
civilization to unearth the secrets from
within
Brian will offer an open world full of
monsters puzzles as well as the
storyline free of any spoken dialogue
and with a cel-shaded style that appears
to draw inspiration from games like the
Wind Waker or Eco this will be one
journey we can't wait to embark on
well hello good-looking with
environmental puzzles contained by a
seemingly infinite architectural space
manifold garden is proving to be just as
challenging as it is beautiful
early puzzles have shown that sometimes
you'll have to fall far to land on the
correct space so you'll have to get over
any fears of heights you might have but
with a calming aesthetic and serene
audio tracks this game proves to be more
of a relaxing and thoughtful experience
than one for thrills don't let its
pastel palette fool you though manifold
garden is filled with puzzles that will
turn your head inside out and that might
be the best mindset to wrap your brain
around these impossible MC Escher style
structures so those are our picks for
the best upcoming hidden gems of 2017
I'm sure I left some games off this list
that you're dying to play so please if
you have one in mine yell at me in the
comments so I can put it on my radar and
for more coverage on all the best indie
games stay tuned the game spot
[Music]